I'm still pre-diabetic, even though I have given upgrades,
I am taking the supplements to suggest any other suggestions.
Whenever we talked about this, you know,
sometimes again, we don't fit into this mold of,
we're going to, you know, go on a ketogenic-like diet,
which you've basically been on,
and have our body drop into pre-ketone-burning state,
or a ketone-burning state, and full ketosis,
just doesn't always work that way.
So, we just gotta be okay with it not working that way,
and our glucose stayed up at, you know, 98,
but I can't figure out why,
because I don't eat any carbohydrates.
It's just the way it is,
and you can't really make those,
make that happen anymore than you are.
It's certainly going on a faster,
doing some sort of modified path to adopt
in your best interests at this point.
So, we don't want to do that.
You remember one of the worst things you can do
is quit yourself in a state of cacasia
where you're losing weight and you're way underway.
That's just not healthy for your healthy cells.
So again, sometimes doing things that are good
for your healthy cells that seemingly,
all this might help feed a cancer cell back to be careful,
but if it's good for your healthy cells,
sometimes that's the best thing for a person.
So, but I'll tell you, you know,
like I said last week, over and over,
this is one of the most important things
is what goes on between your ears, your stress levels,
your anxiety over your diet,
over your supplements over your cancer.
Is the most critical factor in my opinion?
I was interviewed for something
when I was a couple months ago and somebody said,
well, what's the most critical factor
in helping somebody stop cancer
and it's just like, it just came out immediately
which was what goes on in your head.
So I believe in my life that, you know,
God used cancer to help change, you know,
that's my spiritual walk
and what goes on in my head and myself talk.
It's so important to take that role of, you know what?
I'm gonna do everything I can
and I'm not gonna freak out about anything,
including the results.
And if God wants me to change something,
he's just gonna have to, you know,
get me over the head sometimes.
Sometimes he certainly does that.
But I need to listen and I need to be good at listening
to that still small voice in the Holy Spirit in my life
so he can just tell me what to do.
But I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna worry, I'm not gonna,
you know, because then I'm really making an idol
of my diet and my blood test and my results
and regardless, that's not God's purpose in my life.
And it's not bringing me joy and it's not, you know,
helping me fulfill any purpose
and why God has me stay alive.
He's got me here alive, it's to serve others
and I'm doing no good serving others
by being consumed with myself.
So that's a work in progress
and that's the fight that we're called to fight,
that good fight that we're called to fight
is the fight against our flesh.
And to make sure that we are serving God,
the way we're supposed to be serving Him
and not be too self-consumed at least for myself.
Now that's a struggle.
It's a struggle for a lot of us,
but certainly my struggle and it's within,
we just keep fighting that fight.